there is no neutral ground anymore  that time is long since passed  are you going to run around babbling  absolute gibberish  at the behest of narcissists Intoxicated  by the stench of their own farts are you  going to do that are you actually going  are you willing to do that  even if up until this moment you were  the sort of person who said I just want  to be polite and I want to get along  with you and it doesn't hurt me if they  want me to use the pronoun really yeah I  mean it doesn't physically actually it  would physically pain me to use those  pronouns in a non-ironic way but maybe  it wouldn't physically hurt you yet are  you really gonna do that